Hello and welcome to this video on automatic asset prefixes, our fourth example.
Now, just before we jump into the editor, there is a warning which is worth taking
note of when it comes to working with assets.
When you are manipulating assets within Unreal Engine, always opt for the Unreal
editor asset library or on the API or the Unreal asset tools functions.
We want to make sure that we are using the tools provided by the Unreal library, because
if we were to use something like operating system rename or shtil.mov for example, these
would break all of the references.
Unreal functions by having a lot of references to different things.
So if you have something like a material, it might have references to textures or the
actors that it's part of.
By changing the name without using the Unreal library functionality, you're going to break
this and it's going to take a long time to go around cleaning up.
Now in our previous example, we ran a script on startup and that script had a reference
to a number of different tools and functionality in it.
One of the bits that we didn't look at was we had a reference to prefixer.
I'm going to demonstrate this in engine.
But on the startup script, we added an entry into the tools menu script.
And this is going to be a call to a program called prefixer.py, which would be in the
Python folder.
So it means that we can create the function and the trigger where we need it.
So let's have a look at that in the engine.
So here we are back in the engine and we are on slide 10, example four.
Now hopefully this should open up the directory so that you can see the content slides example
four.
And this has got a whole load of materials and static measures.
So if I was to take this torus, for example, and right hand click, you'll now see at the
bottom of this list, we have the Python task section and we have add prefixer.
So if I was to hit that, it's going to go away and you can now see that we have
sm underscore torus.
So this has added a prefix of sm underscore four static mesh.
Now this actually works through, it's not actually the one that I click on, which is
being handed to the prefix.
Actually within the code of the prefix, I am getting selected assets.
So if I was to grab all of these, for example, right hand click and run the add prefixer,
you will see that now it has done this for everything.
So we've got all of the static meshes has sm before them and all the materials have
n for material.
So the code itself doesn't actually matter where it runs from.
You could have it as an editor utility widget or other places.
At any one point, it's getting what you have selected within the browser.
It just makes sense for it to be triggered from a menu option here, because it's a lot
of it is about making sure that the options are where you would expect them to be, where
are the elements.
So you could have an equivalent on here for an asset, which is in the level.
We could create a menu setting from here and we would just use the selected actor
in that case.
Okay, so let's have a quick look at the code.
So here we have the prefixer code and if we look through it, it functions similar
to the other ones that we've worked with.
In this case, we have the system library unreal and we got all of our prefix mappings
in this case.
So what I've done is I've just made the list of all the different classes that you
can have.
It's not extensive, but you can always add extra ones in and it will cycle through.
So it gets the selected assets.
You can see here, get selected assets from the other two utilities and it will cycle
through all of the different selected assets and rename it and save it so that we've
got what we need.
Okay, relatively straightforward, but a very useful script.
And that brings us to the end of our video, automatic asset prefixes example number four.
And in the next video, we will be jumping into our last example.